There are three kinds of inflammation in the rife.
They are all 36 minutes.
How can we know what is each frequency
for and for one organ?
Not exactly sure what you're asking
are three programs for inflammation in their rife.
I'm not positive what you're asking there.
Now let's talk about rife programs
running other programs for a second.
So let's say I have a sinus infection
or you have inflammation.
Well, what program should I run?
Well, if there's an inflammation program,
you can try that.
If there's a swelling program, you can try that.
I have sinus infections.
Well, goodness, there's four or five sinus infection programs.
So which one should I use?
The answer is these are frequencies.
They're different frequency sets
that practitioners like me have created
that have worked for some people.
So try them.
You just have to try all of them.
Try them at different times
and you have to try them more than once.
I ran the stubborn sinus program
and it didn't help at all.
Run it again.
Run it three or four times.
It's still not helping.
Well, maybe run a different sinus program.
Well, maybe run a bacterial program.
Maybe run a virus program.
So you kind of have to think through this a little bit.
Don't feel bad about trying different things.
So these are frequencies.
So a frequency may really help you.
It made for one thing and it might not help you
for something else that's similar to that.
That's why there's multiple programs
for strap infection.
Why are there multiple programs?
Because there's not just one frequency for strap.
So you want to run these different programs
in experiment with them and try them.
That's why I think these should be your first go-to.
So it's not a cure all.
It should be your first go-to
with any symptom that you have.
Long time ago, I shared,
I probably haven't shared it for a while,
that this is, oh gosh, it was like eight, nine years ago.
I had a frozen shoulder.
I hurt my left shoulder, really bad lifting weights.
And I couldn't move my arm.
I couldn't move my shoulder.
I had my arm in a sling for two weeks.
I didn't even think to use the right machine.
Why?
Because it's my shoulder.
I damaged my rotator cuff
or whatever I damaged in there.
I thought I was going to have to do a new surgery.
Finally, my wife said,
you just need to call the orthopedic surgeon
and go in, you're being so stupid here in your stubbornness.
Okay, I can be an extremely stubborn person.
So, and then my colleague at the time,
a doctor that I had worked for me,
he said, why don't you run the rife
and try the accelerated healing program.
I did that first one thing that I had and it worked.
It could be honest with you,
I never thought of it,
every across my mind to run the rife
for my damaged shoulder
because I thought I tore my rotator cuff.
I was pretty sure I had torn it.
My arm was at a sling.
I was taking Tylenol every three hours during the day
and I never take Tylenol.
So that's how painful it was.
I ran the accelerated healing program
which is in the normalizing frequency folder of your rife.
It took my pain away completely.
And how I do it is that,
first of all, I didn't have pigs,
I was taking Tylenol every three hours
and I had to take it or when I paid ramped up.
I forgot to take Tylenol
because I didn't have the pain
because the program fixed it.
I still don't know physiologically how that worked.
But I read it one time,
this is before I had a rife at home.
I didn't have a rife at home at that time.
So it had about nine years ago.
And I ran it at the office.
I ran the accelerated healing program
which is about an hour to half.
I still kept my arm in a sling
because that was a good bit.
So if I take this out of my sling,
it's just going to go, yay!
And just give me a zegger
and I thought I'm just going to keep it in the sling.
Friday, I was at home.
I still kept it in the sling
and I thought this is really stupid.
But my pain is gone.
I got to take the sling off.
So I took the sling off right after a dude
and my arm was still stuck in that sling position
because it'd been like that for two weeks.
And I slowly by Saturday,
I was kind of putting my arm down by my side
and slowly moving it
because I was convinced it was just going to flare up again
and be back to the way it was.
And I was convincing my brain
and I'll guess I'll just hold my arm
in a sling position the rest of my life to be on a pain.
But slowly moved it around.
The pain never came back.
I did the program again Monday when I came in the office
and I think I did it one more time.
The pain never returned.
I can lift weights.
I don't have any problems with my left shoulder.
I don't know how it fixed it.
Maybe it just blocked the pain cycle enough that it healed
but I can't believe that's the truth
because Tyler blocked the pain cycle
and it wasn't healing.
So whatever it worked, it's frequencies.
So when people go,
why don't believe in frequencies?
Okay, well then stop using your cell phone.
The stop, stop living
because everything is frequencies.
So if you hit the right frequencies,
good things can happen.
So don't, don't feel bad about experimenting
with that tool that you have in your house.
One of the saddest thing that we see is we have patients
that will pass away and we'll get the knife back from them
and we have a way to look on the knife
and see the last time you used it,
I shouldn't be telling you this,
but we have a way to look
and you see this person passed away in March
and they stopped using the knife.
They haven't used it for seven months.
It's like what the means?
You have this great tool,
though it's not a magic wand.
It is amazing.
So use it, use it for whatever you want to use it for.
You're not gonna burn the thing out.
You're not gonna hurt yourself with it.
Use this thing.
An experiment with different frequencies
and different programs tell you,
find and hit on what's gonna be best for you.
Currently on our house, we have two rifes in our house.
My grown kids all have a rife machine at their house,
using it for my grandkids or whatever they have going on.
You should use this tool to the best of your ability.